we've got a voicemail number it is 2192
David P Grady called in Grady the
biggest football fan in the David Pacman
show audience that we are aware of he
called in he did not like our interview
earlier this week with the co-writer of
the expanse series of books and producer
of the TV show uh Daniel Abraham he
didn't like it one bit take a
listen hey David it's Grady um I don't
know if I was just distracted or if I'm
just not interested in the subject
matter but Monday's interview was a
total
dud um check you later homie chow chow
yeah that was an interview where the
people who like sci-fi and TV shows and
books and whatever they loved that
interview some of the most positive
feedback we've gotten in the last year
about interviews was in response to the
Daniel Abraham interview you but then
you've got a whole bunch of our audience
who just didn't care about it whatsoever
I love how Grady starts out by saying
that he might have just not been paying
attention right it's like well then how
can you complain pay attention Grady
please pay pay attention and then
comment yeah listen that was a niche
topic a lot of people liked it some
people just didn't care about it but
we're mixing it up all right we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
for membership get instant access to the
bonus show David pacman.com membership